hello I'm Greg circle let's go and today
today we're gonna talk about Vlad the
Impaler the real man behind Dracula
so it's 14:47 and Vlad the third from
Wallachia is a political prisoner than
the Ottoman Empire Vlad is like I want
to go back to my dad my prince my
narrative throne and Radu
Vlad's brother is like I kind of like it
here I really like the salt and son
mehmed ii amendments like i like you too
and then out of nowhere this Boyer shows
up this nobleman and he's breathless
he's like flat
I've bad news your father is dead his
daddy was killed by rival boyars and
Vlad is like I'd like to avenge my
father's death please can you please
release me and they're like okay but rod
who's gonna stay here if that's cool and
riders like yeah I love it here so he
rides to a Lakia keeps down the door and
he's like you're gonna take away our
freedoms Oh
watch ah oh
anyway he's like sweet pretty much
Prince of Wallachia let's have a party
yeah and he invites all of these boyars
he's like guys let's bury the hatchet I
know you killed my father that's fine
you don't worry but don't worry about it
you killed my dad that's okay so the
boyars know like we'll do whatever you
feel like is good and they like drink
and have a great time and then they're
gonna leave and they're like great thank
you so much vide we had such a great
time we're gonna head out in floods like
yeah
yeah shut the doors all the borders like
where what
so Vlad's like you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna take a steak that's like
sharpened almost to a point kind of not
to a point a little around it and I'm
gonna shove it up your butt home and
then I'm gonna go in your esophagus and
I'm gonna stick it out your mouth I'm
going to impale you and he does that to
two hundred boyars it's it's sadistic
then he bailed
two hundred boyars in his court Vlad is
like call me Dracula so is it go around
doing this to everybody
he's like you you look like you're an
adulterer you you look like you're lazy
you you big you're a thief I'm gonna
bail all of you and he impales and he
burns the whole town to the ground and
there's a German monk there and he's
like pint gulp he's dipping his bread in
the blood of his victims
odious eating it that's a vampire
he installers in store ders and he
instills order in vilaça so Mehmet is
like your brother wants to be called
Dracula and brothers like thank you uh
that just means like son of Dracula
which we both are that's lame mm it's
like we should definitely attack flat
because flats being a super dick so
Mehmed crosses into Milwaukee Oh with
these like 60,000 troops and Dracula's
like I get it I'm outnumbered so I'm
gonna retreat but what I want you guys
to do my
Colonels and lieutenants in generals and
I want you to burn
everything and they're like alright but
we're like up our own land and he's like
yes destroy Wenlock yaki so they do it
and they got everything
[Music]